Artificial intelligence and automation
are also playing a growing role.
AIdriven machinery can analyze soil
conditions, monitor crop health, and
even automate complex tasks like
targeted pesticide application or
harvesting. Drones and robotics are
being deployed for crop monitoring,
precision spraying, and repetitive
fieldwork, giving farmers detailed
insights, and freeing up valuable time.
Sustainability is at the heart of these
advancements.
Fuelee efficient and electric machines,
smart irrigation systems, and innovative
soil management tools are helping
farmers reduce their carbon footprint,
conserve water, and improve soil health.
As these technologies become more
accessible, even smaller farms are
finding ways to integrate them, often by
combining new tools with existing
equipment to enhance efficiency and
sustainability. In summary, the
agricultural machinery landscape in 2025
is defined by autonomous and electric
equipment, precision farming
technologies, AI and robotics, and a
strong focus on
sustainability. These innovations are
not only addressing labor shortages and
operational costs, but are also paving
the way for a smarter, greener future in
agriculture.